في اعقاب الكثير من الكوارث والاسيما
الكبيره منها تطلع السلطات والمنظمات
والمجتمعات المحليه والسكان والمتطوعون
بمهام عمليه انتشار وجمع الجثث وادارتها
الفوريه ويعرقل جهود الانقاذ والبحث عن
المفقودين والجثه في حاله ليبيا تركم
الحطامي وغمر المياه لاماكن كثيره لهذا
تشير بروتوكولات الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيه
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر الى ضروره
الاسراع في تحديد الوكاله المسؤوله في
مجال اداره الجثث مع منحها مطلق الصلاحيات
والمسؤوليات التي تشمل جمع المعلومات
وتوحيدها ووضعها في سجل المركزي مع
التواصل مع الناس في هذا السياق جاء اعلان
النائب العام الليبي وضع خطه بالتعاون مع
وزاره الداخليه والصحه لتحديد جثث
المفقودين والتعرف على هويتهم ووفق دليل
اداره الجثث بعد الكوارث للاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
ينبغي جمع وتصويرها فوتوغرافيا باسرع وقت
ممكن قبل تحللها وجمع المعلومات الاساسيه
عنها مع تسجيلها وتخصيص رمز دليلي خاص لكل
جثه وينبغي تخزين الجثث مؤقتا لحمايتها
وتيسير التعرف على هويات اصحابها كما يجب
وضع قائمه تضم اسماء المفقودين وجمع
المعلومات عنهم تحديد هويه الجثث تحد اخر
عام 84 وضع الانتربول بدعم من الفريق
العامل المعني بتحديد هويه ضحايا الكوارث
اول دليل للتحديد هويه ضحايا الكوارث ويمر
ذلك باربع مراحل اولاها فحص مسرح الحدث
ويمكن ان يستغرق اياما او حتى اسابيع
وبيانات ما بعد الوفاه من خلال مختصين في
الادله الجنائيه بما يساعد على تحديد هويه
الضحيه وبيانات ما قبل الوفاه بتحصيل
السجلات الطبيه او المتعلقه بالاسنان
وبصمات الاصابع والبصمه الوراثيه ثم
مطابقه معلومات ضحايا من لم تحدد هويتهم
بالمعلومات عن المفقودين لعل الحاله
الليبيه في خصوصيتها مع جرف السيول الالاف
ومساحات واسعه ومبانيه وسيارات تكمن في
صعوبه تحديد العدد الحقيقي والنهائي
للضحايا بل والمفقودين ففي ظروف الفوضى
التي تسود في حالات الكوارث كمثال غالبا
ما يتم الابلاغ عن شخص مجهول المصير عده
مرات لجهات مختلفه من جانب افراد اسرته
والى ان تتضح الصوره يبقى عداد الموت
والمفقودين مفتوحا فالعثور على جثث يعني
بدايه مسار للتعرف عليها لكن المفقود يبقى
اكبر ضاغط نفسي على عائله تنتظر خبرا
بشانه وقد لا تعرف عائله اخرى اصلا ان
لديها مفقودين في السيول ففي حالات عده
جرفت السيول عائله ممتده باكملها فغرقت
معها قصتها ولم يبقى منها من يرويها